i mean i think wind waker is great i
think
ah you could you could pick wind waker
or breath of the wild as number one and
i i'd be i you know i can't hate on both
right because i mean at the end of the
day but like
like a lot of people who grew up my age
they put ocarina of time and
i
i kind of got bored of ocarina of time
like i kind of did it it's like how
like i think wind waker again it's like
the art style right when wicket aged
[ __ ]
fantastically mm-hmm ocarina did not age
well
like you played that [ __ ] now it is like
[ __ ] impossible to play
like i've always said like ocarina of
time for the zelda franchise is a lot
like final fantasy 7 for the final
fantasy franchise where it's like
because it was the first 3d game yeah
after a long succession of 2d games
obviously when the 3d like [ __ ] was
starting right
right so people immediately were like
it's in 3d
automatically 10 out of 10. i also
didn't grow up with it so
you know i i ended up playing it later
oh yeah
even like now right to me when i you
know who
i've played all the games from wind
waker onwards
i just think like when i'm looking at
ocarina of time like you know
majora's mask looks so much more
interesting oh yeah in like every single
way this game looks [ __ ] weird i
agree yeah
it's so cool but like have you ever
played majora's mask i did like
about two hours and then i was like [ __ ]
this is so hard
hard really hard no i would 100 prefer
playing majora's master over ocarina of
time just because like
again like it's well i mean for for one
both are hard as [ __ ]
yeah but like i don't like playing it on
the emulator i don't know why someone
feels wrong about playing nintendo 64.
yeah because i have majora's mask on
like because i have like a proper nc
yeah i know you do and i have majora's
mask yeah and it's like i don't know the
feeling is kind of the same
to me yeah i don't know maybe it's like
yeah
i want to go back and play them yeah but
again like i don't understand people who
are like
ocarina of time is the greatest zelda
game i'm like i'm sorry
it's not it's not it hasn't i'm gonna
get a whole lot
about it but it's the look i've i've
publicly said
that yeah i'm sorry but final fantasy
vii is not the best it's
again it's it's what combo bomb is to
animate right it's like it's the one
that's what it is that's what it is it's
like it's the one you probably watched
first it's the one that probably got
you into the franchise or into the
medium right but that doesn't mean it's
the best
yeah i mean i i agree because these
might be the ones from my childhood that
you know i have the fondest memories of
but they weren't the first zelda or
mario that i played in my life i'm
surprised you didn't have uh super mario
64 on there
because he's you're such a boomer
these aren't boomer picks darn where are
your boomer picks
these are way too new because the thing
is i'm not like a super massive mario
fan i i did you know i have
i have completed 64 completed sunshine
completed what's the most recent mario
game
honestly honestly i mean i completed
them not not got all the shiny
shines or you know but i got to the end
game beat bowser the final time yeah um
so
you know i have completed them but out
of all the marios that i've played
i just think there's something about
sunshine you know you know when you
think back to a game and you just it
just vibes with you
like like the feeling just vibes yeah
that's sunshine i feel like sunshine is
just clean
okay it's so goddess it's literally in
the name
sunshine okay if you couldn't tell i'm a
bit of a summer kid
right i mean we've had many arguments
about this where like i
[ __ ] does that does that mean
anything it does just because i like the
winter i'm not going to go get [ __ ]
mario at the [ __ ] winter olympics all
right he's playing he's playing [ __ ]
mario 64 gets to the snow level turns it
off
no no that is exactly what happened like
[ __ ]
you know you know there are some levels
out there where you you hit you hit it
and you're just like
oh it's this level again like every
[ __ ] water level in any [ __ ] video
game of all time but i'm not like oh
[ __ ] you know what's one thing i
hate about the stage the weather i've
never been like i am literally like that
like what is wrong with you like when i
played mario's sunshine
and like i i loved it because every
level is like
every level gives off that summer
feeling and that summer vibe
which i [ __ ] love yeah and it's like
the the ones that i hated the levels
that i hated the most
in mario sunshine were like the blue
levels something where it's like dark
and
scary level [ __ ] yeah the pachinko level
is the [ __ ] one
yeah yeah but like for the most part
it's it gives off a very summery vibe
and
i think back to that i'm just like yeah
i [ __ ] with this
i'm i'm used joey samia i [ __ ] [ __ ]
with this you know i
i it just it just makes me happy it
gives me the good feeling
i get that i get that they're like it's
like so hard to there's gonna be such a
boring part of their podcast where we're
just like damn gone you have
good t i mean like this is categorically
just two great games
yeah i mean like exactly congratulations
guys
oh god i've become connor now
this is super vanilla
i mean i'll i'm not i'll happily say
that this is super vanilla um
i mean it's also just interesting
because it's like i think it's because
we just
never [ __ ] talk about the games that
we're into so like i never expected like
subnautica like gears war to be there